recent proposals to expand and reform
the child tax credit
have gained significant attention in
congress when considering such reforms
it's important to understand the tax
benefits currently available
the federal income tax provides a number
of family tax benefits
including the head of household filing
status and tax credits for children
and child care expenses in 2021
the total value of these benefits is 209
billion dollars
and the average benefit per household
with children is almost
4 600 this includes a 2 000
partially refundable child tax credit
the distribution of these benefits is
highly progressive meaning that lower
income households
receive a larger benefit relative to
their income than higher income
households
current proposals would increase the
child tax credit and make the credit
fully refundable meaning the credits
available regardless of income
therefore these proposals all reduce
poverty rates unfortunately
by eliminating the phase-in of the
credit these proposals would also raise
marginal tax rates on work
for low-income households with children
should congress expand the child tax
credit
let us know in our poll also let us know
what other topics
you'd like our scholars to cover in 60
seconds and be sure to like and
subscribe
for more research and videos from aei